Marjorie Taylor green accuses one of the
journalists on the panel of being a
Democrat activist so-called because of a
question he asked take a look at this
and we need to what can you tell me give
me an example no you do this every time
we have a debate where you at I ask a
question that's obvious and you're like
what you mean you were kicked off with
your committees for saying things were
controversial you've apologized for
controversial statements right those
types of things what is your process for
fact checking and vetting the things
that you say in public I the the things
I say in public are the truth and that's
why they're so offensive to democratic
at this in the media just like you
notice how that's not an answer that's
not well here's how I fact check no it's
you're a Democrat activist for even
asking that and you're asking me a
blanket question with no example I stand
by the things that I say I stand by she
stands by It Whatever It Is she stands
by it and of course she said some
horrible things